Hindu a person who follows the religious
scriptures of Hinduism then I have got
no objection as long as that Hindu
strictly follows the established truths
of the scriptures of Hinduism.
Established truths means those truths
mentioned in the Hindu scriptures which
have been confirmed by the last and
final revelation of God. There is a
Buddhist
Quran and I'm referring to Vedas and the
Quran which are mentioned in my
lectures. Both of them they believe that
there is one God. They believe in the
messengers. They believe in the last
messenger is prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. They believe in the hereafter.
If they believe in all these established
facts, I have got no
objection.
Mashallah. The questioner has repeated
plans in detail. Mashallah. If this is
exactly about the Hindu beast, then what
makes them different from a
Muslim? Is there no religion just a term
at this point? Can a Muslim and Hindu
get married? If not, then why not? I'd
really appreciate your answer on this.
Thank you.
In the ending the question has posed
that if she follows the truth or if that
Hindu followed the truth in the Hindu
scripture which is established by the
Quran and
the
meaning if you follow those of Hindu
scripture which
[Music]
established meditations of Quran and
then what is the
Cor you're right. If the person follows
the established teachings in the Hindu
scripture which are mentioned in the
Quran and say then he becomes a
Muslim he has to become a Muslim. He has
to believe there's one God. He has to
believe prophet the last and final
messenger of God. And this messenger in
the scriptures and I've proven in my
lecture that even the Hindu should
believe in one true God who has no image
etc. And they should believe
and also in the last and final messenger
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
these two are the most important
criteria for anyone to accept Islam. So
my answer was very clear that if there
really two practices Hindus based on the
teachings of the Hindu scriptures which
match with the Quran and they are
Muslims what is the
difference? The difference is that Hindu
as a mission may talk is a geographical
definition. Those people living in the
land of the Indas Valley civilization or
those people living in India they are
called as Hindus. It's a geographical
definition. It is not a religious
definition. The right word should be
vant a person who follows the Vedas
should be called a vantist and not a
Hindu. A Hindu is a
misnomer. So in that context I am from
India. I live in India. I'm a Hindu. But
geographical definition. But the real
Muslim is a person who submits to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. So if a person who
believes in the Hindu teachings by the
Quran and they believe that there is one
God and they believe that prophet
Muhammad is the messenger of God, they
are Muslims. So they become Muslims. the
right word Muslim.
So inshallah we pray to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala that may your father and your
mother and your brothers and sisters
inshallah they become Muslims they
follow Allah and his fool because only
one god and though there are many
facilities that are there but if you
believe in one god and believe in the
last and final revelation of Allah
subhana wa t'ala then you are a Muslim
you enter the fold of Islam and
according to you should believe because
you don't know how long a person will
live whether we will see tomorrow or not
we don't know so my request to you be
see to it that you follow the Quran and
say hope that answers the